mercredi c'est le 1er avril
et puisque c'est le premier jour du mois
c'est aussi le moment de payer son loyer
pour les quelques 40 % de québécois qui
sont locataires mais la situation risque
d'être difficile pour des milliers de
travailleurs qui ont perdu leur emploi
dans les dernières semaines et qui n'ont
pas encore reçu l'aide promise par le
gouvernement fédéral certains demandent
même un report du paiement des loyers
pendant cette crise ou même l'annulation
du loyer véronique laflamme et porte
parole du frapru
le front d'action populaire en
réaménagement urbain bonsoir madame la
flamme et hans brouillette directeur des
affaires publiques de la corpiq la
corporation des propriétaires
immobiliers du québec qu'on soit
monsieur brouillette
bonjour monsieur fillion madame la
flamme d'abord est ce que vous êtes
inquiète de la quantité de personnes qui
n'arriveront peut-être pas à payer leur
loyer demain très inquiète quand on
connaît les chiffres du dernier
recensement on sait que 460 mille
ménages locataires déjà consacré plus de
la norme de 30 % de leur revenu pour se
loger au québec
deux cent mille d'entre eux et elles
paient plus de la moitié de leur revenu
pour se loger alors le calcul est simple
ans avec le chômage à 55 % de son
salaire ce sera très difficile pour des
centaines de milliers de personnes de
payer le loyer et plusieurs des jeunes
pensent ne pas pouvoir y arriver demain
des centaines de milliers dit vous est
ce que vous êtes dans les mêmes
évaluations en brouillette
mais non on est prêt et le clan puisque
madame notre homme ne dit pas c'est que
sophie centaines de milliers beaucoup
sont prestataires des différentes formes
des aides gouvernementales que ce soit
de l'assistance sociale que ce soit
l'assurance emploi que ce soit dit grant
pour les personnes âgées à différentes
situations alors bien sûr ces gens là
n'ont pas été affectés par les pertes
d'emplois des dernières semaines
oui il y aura certainement beaucoup
beaucoup de gens incapables de payer
demain mais sont tout ce n'est qu'une
question de temps puisqu'on atteint le
programme ne ferra l'hiver sera fait dès
fédérale qui devrait donner de 1000 $
par personne qui a perdu son arc avec
moi les autres des centaines de milliers
absolument folle
est ce que ça vous inquiète quand même
parce qu'on parle d'un appel à la grève
est ce que vous êtes inquiet de voir
beaucoup de gens ne pas payer leur loyer
non je pense que c'est un mouvement que
des halles des anarchistes et activiste
et c'est d'initier mais c'est ça aurait
des conséquences extrêmement rare pour
des locataires d'accumuler des loyers
impayés
on sait évidemment que le risque est
grand de perdre éventuellement leur
logement d'avoir une décision du
tribunal contre eux est-ce qu'il faut
plutôt regarder c'est quelles sont les
modalités pour payer sur le web
il ne pourra certainement pas là être
demain pour bien les ménages locataires
mais vous savez les propriétaires et les
locataires sont capables de certaines
patientes au frapru est ce que vous
encourager des gens ne pas payer leur
loyer
non en fait ce n'est pas en fait c'est
très difficile de toute façon pour le
frapru et les comités logement qui en
sont membres actuellement d'organiser un
mouvement d'aller dans les appartements
les gens commençaient à l'habitude pour
mobiliser parce que les gens ne peuvent
pas se déplacer
par contre nous on porte des demandes
politiques au gouvernement
on a écrit la semaine dernière à la
ministre responsable de l'habitation
on comprend les préoccupations des
locataires et des gens qui quand même en
ne savent pas comment ils vont payer
demain
il ya des propriétaires qui envoie
actuellement des lettres ou locataires
leur rappelant que le loyer et du le
premier comme à l'habitude alors même si
le premier ministre legault a appelé les
propriétaires à être compréhensif binbin
les locataires reçoivent des lettres
actuellement et on leur dit votre loyer
et du comme à l'habitude d'attendre et
éclaire la part du gouvernement
ça repose encore une fois sur les
épaules de jacques sont absolument
vulnérables face à la situation actuelle
mais il ya un moratoire quand même qui
est en place qui était qui interdit les
évictions donc les gens ont une forme de
protection oui cette protection là ce
moratoire là on a salué dure seulement
le temps de l'urgence sanitaire
nous ce qu'on craint c'est une vague
d'éviction une fois que la période
d'urgence sanitaire sera terminée parce
que les audiences à la régie sont
suspendus mais on peut quand même être
réduire des demandes alors qu'en aussi
que la défense il ya peu de défense
possible dans des codes de non-paiement
la régie du logement
ce qu'on craint c'est qu'une série
d'éviction une fois l'urgence sanitaire
terminée et que les gens finalement
se passait bien c'est perdre leur
logement à raison d'une exceptionnelle
d'ailleurs monsieur brouillette si je me
trompe pas vous encourager les
propriétaires à s'inscrire tout de suite
à la régie du logement pour être prêt à
procéder aux évictions lorsque le
moratoire va tomber on vous a critiqué
un peu pour cette position là pourquoi
vous lancer cet appel là parce qu'on
sait pas combien de temps va durer la
crise y ont aussi comme si ni le qatar
qui avait déjà pas pays février mars
il ya des locataires aussi de mauvaise
foi qui chercheront à profiter de la
situation pour ne pas payer donc on doit
le dire vraiment deux catégories de
stratégie avec des locataires de
mauvaise foi ne tardez pas parce que
plus vous inscrivez vite la cause plus
vite vous sera entendue lorsque la régie
on réactivera c'est ses audiences par
contre pour tous les autres locataires
des gens qui ont perdu leur emploi
normalement s'il n'y avait pas de crise
ce serait la même chose des
propriétaires se moque flexible avec des
locataires qui s'engage à payer leur
loyer même si actuellement ou
temporairement elles vivent une
situation que ce soit une séparation ou
une perte d'emploi duriez qui va changer
là on comprend que des montants sont
sont attendus fédéral ont rapidement
reçu les rassurer les propriétaires qui
devront s'inscrire
c'est ce qui est important il n'y a pas
de raison que des gens soient évincés de
leur logement
s'il utilise la haine fédéral de 2000 $
du fonds d'urgence pour jouer loyer
j'écris je vous donne un exemple il ya
un propriétaire d'immeuble à québec qui
nous dit aujourd'hui j'ai deux blocs 12
logements
j'ai déjà commencé à prendre des
ententes avec mes locataires mais je
peux faire ça un mois ou deux j'ai vidé
mes comptes des banques pour être
certain de voir les liquidités pour
payer mon hypothèque donc jusqu'à quel
point ce type d'entente là peut vraiment
fonctionné madame la flamme ben écoutez
d'abord c'est ça les ententes ça de sa
demeure des ententes de gré à gré il ya
des propriétaires actuellement qui donne
une fin de non-recevoir aura des gens
qui voudraient bien avoir une entente de
report de paiement alors c'est pour ça
qu'on pense qu'il faut éviter de compter
sur la bonne volonté des gens et
s'assurer que tout le monde est protégé
ensuite c'est sûr que j'aimerais bien
entendre la corpiq sont les mesures qui
sont elles qui sont demandées aux
banques
parce qu'actuellement il ya des mesures
de report de paiement hypothécaire de
de prévu et on entend très peu
finalement d'impression pour demander au
gouvernement de faire en sorte que les
banques finalement mettre en place des
mesures qui vont s'appliquer à tous
messieurs brouillette a tué après les
banques
on s'attend donc un cadeau des banques
on peut bien le demande et même le
gouvernement fédéral avait dit bon on
est l'assurance que les banques
pourraient reporter les cyprès qui s'en
charge et d'intérêts non le professeur
jusqu'à maintenant les discussions qui
ont eu lieu entre des membres de
l'accord paix et leur prêtant
hypothécaire ce à l'effet que oui dans
certaines circonstances si effectivement
il ya une incapacité de payer pour le
propriétaire
le montant pourrait être recapitalisées
avec les intérêts qui courent donc il y
aurait une déchéance à payer
éventuellement les propriétaires devront
payer mais on peut se poser la question
puis madame la flandre je sais que vous
êtes et c'est odieux de soulever sa
messi pendant toutes ces années là au
lieu de vous opposer au dépôt de
garantie vous aviez accepté qu'on est au
québec comme partout ailleurs dans le
monde dépôt de garantie on n'en serait
pas là aujourd'hui les échangeurs droit
où le loyer d'avril n'est pas payé
d'avancés changerait quoi ça changerait
quoi monsieur brouillette y aurait un
coussin il y aurait un coussin d'un mois
pour les locataires jusqu'à ce que
l'aide fédérale
je cède à cheminer et qu'il aide
fédérale je le rappelle c'est resservira
doit servir à aider écouter d'abord
force est faux de dire qu'on est le seul
endroit mais concrètement on trouve ça
déplorable on trouve ça déplorable que
la corpiq utile et la situation
d'urgence actuelle la situation en fait
2 dans laquelle se trouvent les milliers
de personnes pour repousser sa demande
politique d'avoir un dépôt de garantie
qu'on parle de centaines de milliers de
gens qui vivent finalement qui
consacrent une part disproportionnée de
leur revenu pour se loger ces gens là on
peut plus l'argent pour payer un loyer
d'avancé ses loyers leur rappelons le
sont à 1000 1500 $ de plus en plus le
problème c'est aussi la cherté des
logements si on veut changer le des bols
on pourrait aussi parler du contrôle des
loyers des promesses
si on pense que la situation pour quoi
faire ils conservateurs savent être là
moi je veux juste savoir est-ce qu'on
pourrait en 15 secondes monsieur
brouillette reporté des paiements à plus
tard pour les locataires
c'est évident que le kata qui pourront
pas payer nos repas de risque des
fictions a couru même
bien terne le temps que l'argent arrive
du fédéral oui on aurait souhaité un
programme provincial il y en a pas pour
le moment vient il y aura cet argent à
payer pour le loyer et vous madame la
flamme est ce que vous êtes d'accord
pour dire que les propriétaires aussi
subissent quand même cette crise là en
ce moment il ya des propriétaires que
oui dont tournai fonds de prévoyance et
qui font des profits faramineux depuis
des années donc il ya des petits
propriétaires occupants il ya des
grosses compagnies et la majorité des
locataires ont une grande compagnie un
gros propriétaire comme propriétaire
alors pour faire attention de qui on
parle mais est ce vraiment et pour
interpeller les banques et le
gouvernement et oui il faut absolument
s'assurer de protéger les locataires ne
pourront pas payer de faim alors il le
gouvernement dit qu'il faut agir
c'est une situation très importante
encore une fois le pote tout à fait
réglée ce soir mais c'est intéressant de
vous entendre merci beaucoup véronique
laflamme et hans brouillette
merci